thirty percent on your first auto ship
order visit chewy.com today
one in five transgender americans has
been homeless
at one time or another adriana diaz
found a tennessee nonprofit
giving permanent housing to some of
those who are most at risk
one tiny home at a time if you go to
survival kits
i can do banana pudding every thursday
at this park in memphis
you can find kayla gore handing out hot
meals and hope
to those living on the streets
kayla herself was homeless 10 years ago
other people who were experiencing
homelessness
kind of showed me how to stay safe
because i'm a transgender woman i'm
black so they taught me how to sleep on
top of buildings
how to hide my clothes during the day
being cared for by the community is what
informs her work now
at my sister's house an organization she
co-founded in her hometown of memphis
that provides emergency housing to
transgender people in need
a lot of people will not understand like
the experiences of trans people not
having access to jobs
in the first place we have access to
menial jobs like in a warehouse
tennessee is an at-will state so you can
be fired for any reason or no reason
she says trans people face higher
discrimination at work
which leads to job loss but there's
another issue
a lot of folks don't have addresses
where they can actually put on an
application
to get a job so you can't get a house or
rented apartment because you don't have
a job in
stable employment and it's hard to get
stable employment if you don't have an
address
to show where you live exactly it makes
no sense
trans people are more likely to live in
temporary housing
hotels rooms for rent or staying with
friends and family
situations which can quickly decline to
homelessness
that's especially true for black trans
women more than half of whom
have been homeless then when coveted 19
hit
gore says the demand for housing at her
organization
tripled people weren't able to work
people were being kicked
out of their places and they were coming
here and we didn't have the capacity to
house people
that's when the tiny homes project was
born
[Music]
the mission to build 20 tiny homes for
trans women of color to own
that way they'll never have to rent
again we're in hopes
of acquiring all of these lots
through crowd funding and donations the
nonprofit raised almost 600 thousand
dollars
to purchase land and break ground
and almost a year since the project
began
the first homeowner is alexis jackson
who was once homeless
after a fallout with her family this
would be my keisha's face my stove would
go right here
this 400 square feet is her sanctuary
i was in the depths of alcoholism
financial struggle
and i don't ever want to go back to
where i was at
my living room space and the way my
ceilings are set up that's my favorite
part of my home
providing these homes to trans folks is
giving them that safety and security
a vast majority of the transmitters are
associated
with people who are experiencing
homelessness i feel like harriet tubman
i feel like i'm giving people a pathway
to success in life
harriet tubman had to do her work in
secrecy we're doing it
out loud and proud for cbs this morning
adriana diaz chicago
boys